the ambulance crew were lucky to escape
without a serious injury when settlers
threw rocks at their vehicle last week
they were called out to treat
Palestinians who've been injured when
settlers attacked a village in the
occupied West Bank
I didn't think we would make it out of
there alive we were driving between cars
that were on fire and I would never have
expected that they would attack an
ambulance there were an average of 17
settler attacks a week on Palestinians
in 2022 170 increase in five years
according to the UN
with Israel's new governing Coalition
including far-right ministers elected by
settlers many Palestinians fear the
violence will get worse
the US government says it opposes
settlement expansion and the
legalization of outposts but the Israeli
government is promising to do just that
those new gray and white Apartments over
there are illegal settlements right here
in the heart of the West Bank and last
year just three percent of police cases
involving settler violence resulted in a
conviction
fera salami is from an Israeli group
that monitors settler attacks he says
they now have no fear and come right
into the villages
they're emboldened because Israeli law
enforcement gives them impunity and the
power to carry on and escalate when
there is no accountability the attacks
increase and so does the violence today
because they are in a position of power
within the government they feel more
immune settlements started appearing not
long after Israel occupied the West Bank
in the 1967 arab-israeli war there are
now around 290 of them all illegal under
international law
the settlements in Blue on this map are
gradually expanding and will eventually
join together a tactic Palestinian
official Hassan glass says was used when
Israel was founded
they want to implement a plan to
transfer Palestinians from areas close
to Settlements a scene similar to that
in 1948 when Zionist gangs committed
massacres and instilled fear to drive
Palestinians out of their homes today we
have another attempt at eugang's new
names price tag Hilltop youth you name
it
no settlers have been charged in
connection with the attack on the
ambulance on Saturday
Israeli police say they'll investigate
the incident
but have yet to make any arrests
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera Ramallah